American intelligence officials say
Russian cyberattacks could threaten the
2018 and 2020 US elections now an essay
in The Washington Post warns Russia
never stopped cyberattacks and the US
government has not done much to stop
them it's written by former Republican
Congressman Mike Rogers and CBS News
senior national security contributor
Michael Morell Morel is a former deputy
and acting director of the CIA he's also
the host of the intelligence matters
podcast Michael Morell is joining us
live from Washington with more Michael
great to see you thank you so much for
coming on and writing that important
piece and it follows up on a Washington
Post report that that lists the all of
the inadequate attempts that the Obama
administration made tried to thwart
Russian meddling now President Trump
doesn't even seem to be acknowledging it
so is Russian meddling just inevitable
in the months and years to come it's not
inevitable there are many things that we
can do about it
there are many things that we can do to
defend ourselves here at home you know
for example we can pass the legislation
that's been proposed that puts the same
rules on political messaging on social
media that we have on TV radio and print
and we can do a better job imposing
costs on Vladimir Putin and Russia to
make Putin think twice about continuing
to do this so there are many things we
can do about this we're just not doing
them it's been reported that the
president has yet to have a cabinet
meeting on this issue Jeff Sessions has
acknowledged that not enough has been
done and many Americans don't seem to
think that this is a pressing issue as
well why do you think that is I don't
know it's a new it's a new type of
attack on America right this is the this
is not a terrorist attack where you can
see the the consequences immediately
it's not a military attack where you can
see the consequences immediately this is
a slow erosion of our confidence in our
democracy this is affecting the way we
think about our country the way we think
about our democracy the way we think
about our society and so it's a new type
of attack and I think that's the primary
reason why we're not focused on it
Michael speaking of Vladimir Putin how
involved is the Russian president and
what is he hoping to accomplish here
that I have I have no doubt that he is
fully involved in this I have no doubt
that he approved this I have no doubt
that he's following it closely he's
trying to accomplish two things one is
he is trying to weaken the United States
weaken our influence overseas so if he
can create discord here at home for us
well he will weaken us overseas the
second thing he's doing which may be the
most important thing from his
perspective is the greatest threat to
him is democracy in Russia and if he can
undermine it in the United States if he
can undermine it in Western Europe he
can raise questions in his own country
about the value of democracy that's very
important to him
you know Michael you also write that
other countries are following suit did
are sort of ignoring this Russian
interference play a role in that as well
absolutely our failure to deter Russia
has led other countries to think that
maybe this is a tool that they can use
so we see the Chinese doing this already
we see the Turks doing this in Western
Europe we see the Chinese doing it in in
Taiwan and so I think more countries are
going to start doing this unless we
deter them from doing so
and they're going to start doing it
against us here at home so the Chinese
have not done it here yet but you can
you can rest assured that they will
unless we deter Russia China and the
other countries that are going down this
road Michael let me ask you because
despite the president not acknowledging
it some argue that those around him that
his advisers have now enlisted
sanctioning three prominent Russians
including the leader of Chechnya and
also now arming the Ukrainian something
that President Obama wouldn't even go as
far as doing is that at least a first
step in deterring Vladimir Putin so
those are those are good steps those are
good things right but but sanctioning
specific individuals will not get Putin
to think about what he has to do here we
need much broader sanctions much more
pain on the Russian economy in the
Russian middle class to get Putin's
attention and he has not yet sanctioned
the Russian sanctions that the President
Obama enlisted as well it's important to
note Michael thank you so much